انفاق غزه هي صداع اسرائيل المزمن طالما
حاولت تدميرها في حروب سابقه اما في هذه
الحرب فاعلنت هدفا رئيسيا الانفاق بالنسبه
الى حماس هي ورقتها الرابحه وسلاحها
الاستراتيجي ففي ظل عدم توازن القوه مع
اسرائيل انشات شبكه معقده تحت الارض
لتحييد التفوق العسكري والتقني لاسرائيل
تقديرات وسائل الاعلام العالميه كانت تشير
الى ان شبكه انفاق غزه تضم
1300 نفق تمتد على طول نحو 500 م يصل عمق
بعضها الى 70 مترا تحت الارض وتنقسم الى
انفاق تامين هجوم ودفاع وامداد وقياده
يعتقد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان ان حماس تحتجز
الرهائن في الانفاق هذه الصور قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انها لاحد الانفاق التي عثر
عليها في خاان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه بطول
اكثر من 800 متر اضاف ان هذه وهذا النفق
بالتحديد استخدم لاحتجاز نحو 20 اسيرا في
فترات
مختلفه لهذا يصر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
اف جالنت على ان الجيش سيواصل حربه على
غزه حتى القضاء على حماس وقدراتها
العسكريه
نستمع لا يمكن انها هذه الحرب من خلال
تسجيل نقاط بل من خلال توجيه ضربه قاضيه
علينا القضاء على حماس اذا اردنا ان نعيش
في هذا المكان وعلى كل ارهابي يوجد في
دائره قطرها مئات الكيلومترات ان يعلم انه
مقابل مثل الافعال التي ارتكبت ضدنا هناك
نتيجه واحده وهي القضاء على القدرات
العسكريه والسلطوية
اربعه اشهر من الحرب هل تمكنت اسرائيل من
تدمير شبكه انفاق حماس او على الاقل تحييد
خطرها الاجابه لدى صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال
الامريكيه التي نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين
واسرائيليين قولهم ان نحو 80% من انفاق
حماس لا تزال سليمه وهو ما يعوق اهداف
اسرائيل الرئيسيه في الحرب الصحيفه اوضحت
ان اسرائيل استخدمت طرقا عده لمحاوله
تدمير الانفاق ومنها تركيب مضخات ضخمه
لاغراق بالمياه تدميرها بالغازات الغارات
الجويه والمتفجرات السائله تفتيشها
بالكلاب والروبوتات وتدمير المداخل اضافه
الى مداهمتها اذا كيف علقتم على هذا الرقم
الذي كشفته صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال دعونا
نبدا هنا بحساب
اروى تقول اروى نشاط حماس في المناطق التي
انسحب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي في شمال غزه
تثير قلقا في اسرائيل 80% من انفاق حماس
وغزه لم يتم تدميرها حتى الان الجيش يعيش
متاه بالبحث عن الانفاق نصل ايضا الى
تعليق علي يقول هذه التصريحات خداعه يريد
الصهاينه تبرير قتلهم للمدنيين وتهجيرهم
وتدمير كل غزه لكي تصبح صالحه للعيش ونصل
ايضا الى احمد يقول احمد جيش من ورق فاشل
مهزوم لم يتمكن من تفكيك شفره الانفاق لم
يتمك من تحرير اسير واحد لا حتى معروف
العدد الصحيح او حتى اماكن تواجدهم ايضا
وصلنا الى سمير اليست مثل هذه التقارير
يراد منها تاجيج الراي العام الغربي ضد
حماس التي حسب دعايتهم ارهابيه وتريد محو
الكيان وننهي ايضا التغريدات بحساب عدنان
يقول الحقيقه التي لا يجرؤ العدو على
قولها انه هزم في غزه وانها اصبحت مقبره
له وانه الاليات العسكريه اصبحت طعم سهل
لقذائف الياسين البعض يتساءل هل توقعت
اسرائيل حجم الانفاق قبل الدخول في الحرب
صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت الاسرائيليه قالت ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي فوجئ بان حجم شبكه
الانفاق في القطاع يفوق تقديرات القاده
العسكريين بنحو
600% اي بست مرات ما توقعه الاسرائيليون
لكن هل هدف تدمير انفاق حماس في القطاع
واقعي في مقال بعنوان لماذا لن تتمكن
اسرائيل ابدا من تدمير جميع انفاق حماس في
غزه صحيفه هارتس الاسرائيليه تجيب وتقول
قد يكون على الجيش الاسرائيلي الاعتراف
بان هدف تدمير اميال تشبه المتاه لم يكن
واقعيا على
[موسيقى]
الاطلاق
h